richard reeves author of president
kennedy profile of power where do you
put President Kennedy and a 41 man that
had been president United States and
importance and popularity and success I
would put him very high I would probably
put him toward the the bottom of the top
10 maybe the the top of the next round
but I think that it was not all politics
I think that he had enormous impact as a
cultural figure and almost as an artist
in the sense that he made us see things
differently made us see ourselves in our
country differently because he there was
a role model effect I think that of his
coming along when the country first got
very rich and when technology made it
enormous ly richer in a very short
period of time the jet planes being the
best example because they democratized
travel and other things and I think that
people look for role model at that time
as to how we're supposed to act now that
were these kind of rich people and I
think he filled a lot of that and he set
a tone both favorable unfavorable
culturally which was just about don't
wait your turn just go out and do it and
now I think everybody does do that and a
lot of institutions have suffered fairly
and unfairly because of that as a as to
his presidential decisions I would I
would say that he's got two big good
ones and one big bad one and that they
were linked in a certain way I think
that I he was the man who decided alone
really that the United States government
would be on the side of the minority in
in the period of civil rights it would
be on the side of the then Negroes now
we tend to say blacks and up to that
point the government had tried to stay
neutral I think that he handled Europe
in the end quite well I think he did it
in ways we didn't really understand at
the time that the Berlin Wall for all
the celebration of it's coming down it's
going up probably prevented
Foundation between the Soviets and and
the Americans in Berlin in that period
and then he went into Vietnam for all
the wrong reasons but left the country
in it in a terrible position there
because at the time he died we had just
overthrown with him signing off on it a
legitimate government in South Vietnam
because it wouldn't take orders from us
and from then on I think that it was
pretty much an American colony run by
military people who we paid and who we
ordered around as you travel around and
talk to people do Colin chose get
reviewed what's the thing that people go
for first in this book I the thing they
over first ten is not in the book
particularly it's the the similarity
between John Kennedy and and President
Clinton and how alike they were in in
many ways men who have worked their way
to the top pretty much on charm kind of
serial seduction and felt that they feel
that they can always prevail one on one
which kind of a Khrushchev disabused
Kennedy of that a little bit but that
tends to be what the first thing that
comes up what's the first thing in the
book the first thing in the book really
in terms of page one or in terms of
what's most important the thing that
people ask you about once they talk to
you about this book what's the thing
that they always go go to first I
haven't found a pattern yet but I know
where I go first of it I think that I
wanted to write a book about being
president about what it's like to be
president so I tried to isolate
everything I could find into the Oval
Office and and figure out what it was
like to be John Kennedy and what it's
like to be president but the the
reaction that I've had has been has been
very different depending on where it's
coming from you say in the book he never
met President Kennedy I didn't know
Herald with a family I knew Robert
Kennedy pretty well I traveled with him
a couple of years for the New York Times
and I know senator Kennedy Teddy Kennedy
from interviews over the years and being
in the wrong place at the wrong time
with him
but John Kennedy I was in college when
Kennedy ran what you mean by being in
the wrong place at the wrong time
I just meant democratic political
conventions and that kind of but the
kind of places that keep people off the
streets but you do say that you ask Ted
Kennedy three times to talk to you about
this book and he turned you down all
three times no he would not talk about
it I don't know why did you try to go to
friends and all I did I went through I
went through in and I more or less
consider him a friend but he didn't want
to do it and other people who talked to
him would not do it the I don't think I
was I know the rules always stories
about how the the family has hindered or
helped people I don't think they did
either to me mrs. Kennedy Jacqueline
Kennedy agreed to answer fact-checking
questions through a third party her
secretary and I talked at some length to
Steve Smith the president's
brother-in-law who I'd known for a long
time and beyond that the the real
problem of doing things like this on the
Kennedys is that they run the library
they run the Kennedy Library and it is
less user friendly and less research
friendly than the other presidential
libraries are worked in on this book a
lot of the Kennedy stuff is from the LBJ
library but both the Eisenhower and
Johnson libraries are much more friendly
excuse me and you don't get the sense
that they're trying to defend a position
I personally think that there is family
should not have control of these
libraries this is the public's business
and I don't I have no great anger about
it but I think that a lot I could have
been saved a lot of time a lot of other
things if the Kennedy Library were as it
were a non connected institution you
write about that in the back explain a
lot about the Kennedy Library and other
libraries let me go back first before I
get into that and ask you when did you
start this book I started about six and
a half years ago I had read a book
called the emperor by richard kuklinski
the polish journalist about the fall of
Haile Selassie as Emperor of Ethiopia
and I found myself as he described the
court around
Haile Selassie wondering what all this
looked like to the Emperor himself and I
tried to write a novel called the
president's diary trying to look at the
presidency from a president's
perspective it was a failed novel I
hadn't publish it and then I thought I
would try to do the same thing in
nonfiction and that I began the
nonfiction six years ago what were you
doing at that time for a living writing
you know by the pound I I had a cost
syndicated column and I was living when
I began I was actually living in France
and but I was doing my column and then
began the research on on this what made
you think that another Kennedy book
would sell I don't know if I thought of
it in terms of sales at the beginning
and I you know there really only two
Kennedy books so I it by my perspective
with what I tried to do I mean Sorensen
and Schlesinger are where you have to go
to there the the essential books and
then you've got a thousand books which
focus on one thing or another some of
them were important and some of them not
but the I thought there was time to do
an objective book about what happened in
those three years and I thought I had
found a different way to do it that is
that there are not the scenes are
Kennedy I mean we're next to Kennedy in
that book this is what he sees this is
what he hears this is what he read and
this is what he what he does so that I
didn't have that sense point beginning
outside the country might have
inoculated me a little bit from people
telling me what are you crazy writing
another book on on the Kennedys who
cares
what were you doing in France living you
know writing and my wife was the public
affairs director of the Herald Tribune
and how did you start a book like this
over in France I mean what what was at
you you know what kind of libraries were
at your room elbow there that you could
delve into well there was there were
some I thought I did a lot of the work
in Europe in terms of research but that
was mostly Moscow not there was some in
Paris but I came back for long periods
and worked in the Kennedy Library or
collected material too then I would
think that Eden doing a book like this
the firt by the end of the first year
you've got it all figured out by the end
of the second year you know you knew
nothing about what really happened and
then came the four years of of plugging
away but the the first and then of
trying of accumulating it and then of
sculpting it down until I got to what I
thought was John Kennedy inside that but
the first year was largely reading of
material shipped over from from the US
and I had a researcher who who worked
every day in the library so that I could
get a feel of what what was there and
what wasn't you give credit to your
researcher who started with you and as a
student he was a his name is Peter
Keating and he's terrific he I put a
notice on a bulletin board at Harvard I
was the way I wanted someone to go over
to the Kennedy Library in Xerox things I
was taking from the indexes and I put
and Peter was a junior at Harvard
knocked on my door we have a house in
Long Island the end of Long Island
knocked on our door and who's this Irish
New York political junkie whose mother
was the bursar of the little Catholic
College my wife had gone to st. Joe's in
Brooklyn so it was he was heaven-sent
for me how as I read the book and I kept
seeing quotes or even references to the
present said this and he set up in his
bed and was reading the New York Times
then his breakfast was brought in by the
butler and you go back in the back and
try to find all that some of it's there
I mean it's tremendous number of source
notes and some of it is how does a
writer do that well in the case of a
president I think that there are first
there were many more tapes of things
than anyone ever knew I think anyone
ever knew until now whose Kennedy
history no tapes the the Oval Office in
the Cabinet Room were recorded under
Kennedy same reason that Nixon did it
Kennedy wanted to write his memoirs and
he wanted a record of what had happened
and many of his phone calls were in
those days phone calls were often
monitored by secretaries who kept notes
on them but in his case there was a they
had an invented the tape recorder yet
really there was a wire recorder
controlled by his secretary Evelyn
Lincoln and he would flick a switch and
if he wanted a phone call recorded so
that there was that there what basically
what there is is it people who work for
presidents or who deal with presidents
all right like athletes dying young that
is the peak for most of them is so high
that they were they write down
everything and remember everything so
that in meeting after meeting or scene
after scene I did I was able to talk to
six or eight people who were in a room
of ten and the rest of them had either
notes on what they did or had had talked
about the scene in in their own oral
histories at the Kennedy Library the
oral histories the Kennedy Library were
done mainly in 1964 which was for me a
tremendous help because many people in
1988 tell different stories particularly
about Vietnam than what they were
telling in 1964 so you've got a real
reality check of what of what happened
did you listen to the oral histories or
did you read the transcripts I read them
ug listen will they let you listen to
them if they would let I don't know if I
actually don't know if tapes actually
exist I listen to the tapes of Oval
Office meetings and that kind of thing
which are often difficult they've not
all been transcribed they're often
difficult to hear and in some cables the
cases people like McGeorge Bundy who
were in the room were willing to try to
figure out parts of them as to who it
was a particular problem this is
probably not a great interest to most
people but it's a problem distinguishing
between the voice of John Kennedy and
Robert Kennedy and on a lot of those
tapes so it takes an enormous
concentration and effort to do it you
also have you find things that and again
I was I wasn't playing or I
I was trying simply to compile as much
as I could on what John Kennedy did say
in this 24-hour period
or whatever Lyndon Johnson had a
military attache name birth who on
national security meetings sat in and
took notes of the vice president who was
rarely there and Colonel Burris was a
terrific reporter and the files in the
LBJ library on some of those meetings
perfectly complement the the official
note-taking records from from the
president's people so that you got a
much richer picture of what happened in
a room how many interviews you did you
did you did I would say it's somewhere
between a hundred and two hundred
probably forty or fifty of those were
were key and really opened my eyes to
new and who was key who was key and then
there were the the interview I will look
back on I think and remember longest
because it was an epiphany for me was
with Steve Smith the president's
brother-in-law who was to be his
campaign manager and the in 1964 BK
because Steve was part of a group of
people he's since died it was part of a
group of people who as far as I could
tell had unresolved doubts in their own
mind about the fact that their lives
became subsumed if that's the word to to
john kennedy's dean rusk falls in that
category Stewart Udall is in that
category fred dutton is in that category
these were all people who Harris Wofford
these are all people who were there but
who never felt what never took the final
Rite of initiation tried to hold some of
themselves back because the
Kennedy was a furnace and in the sense
that if you got near him you melted into
him he was a lovely likable guy to most
people but the people who served him
were not that different than the court
that served Haile Selassie if they got
too close to the Sun as it were so that
those and what Steve Smith told me that
I didn't know
was the the bond between these people in
between John Kennedy in between many of
the people who supported and voted for
him was the war were veterans
Steve rather than as rather than give a
grandiose exposition on why he thought
Kennedy was important in what he had
done and what not tended to shrug it off
and say it was just really the veterans
he was the the first one who came along
and represented the veterans and if you
then went and talked to people within
that context and also if you then went
back and looked at the propaganda movies
in World War two and and realized one of
the principal themes of them was the
Catholics or Americans to that there was
always Richard Conte or William Bendix
in these movies playing a guy from
Brooklyn an Italian guy or an Irish guy
and this was in an accident 30% of the
country was was Catholic Catholics had
always been discriminated against her or
looked down on a bit by the Protestants
from me from the 18th century on and the
it kind of brought me into a whole area
that laid the groundwork for who John
Kennedy was and and and how he was
perceived by the people who might have
supported them or voted for his first
political slogan was the new generation
offers a leader and that was pegged to
veterans who by then were getting antsy
about how the country was going to treat
them who else besides Steve Smith in
that in that group of people no but who
you interviewed and who made a
difference in this book man named Louis
Martin who was the only black man near
Kennedy at all
what is what about his aide George
wasn't George Foster what the Harris
Wofford well I'm sorry though I'm
talking about his ballet Oh George
Thomas there's Thomas right well George
Thomas was a black man but he was he was
his valet he didn't you know that I mean
there was no meaningful communication I
think between although people had
interviewed George Thomas at lines
particularly Jim Bishop if you remember
a day in the life of books but the I
didn't consider that let me stop you
though on that
because you point out that our third
croc provided George Thomas to or
suggested him to John Kennedy who was
Arthur croc and how did that work
Arthur crux funny if Arthur croc ever
knew people had a drug job Arthur Clarke
was the bureau chief of the New York
Times in Washington for years decades he
was also a daily columnist not a daily
comment I think was three columns a week
had great power he was very close to
Kennedy's father and when when Jack
Kennedy was elected to Congress in 1946
I Joe Kennedy asked croc could his son
borrow George
Thomas to take care of him because
Kennedy was not a kind of guy knew how
to take clothes to the cleaners or that
kind of thing I mean he lived a very
scott Fitzgerald
kind of life other peope there were
always people to clean up the messes
whether it was throwing his clothes
there and change clothes five times a
day from the skin out then there were
people George Thomas to picked to pick
those clothes up and to where he had no
idea where they went but they came back
and he's forever questioning people
about how much money they made what they
did with it because he had never really
as they say worked for a living you know
his salaries were from the government
the Navy and the and the presidency and
he donated those to charity so Kroc
delivered
George Thomas that operation crock also
edited Kennedy's first book there why
England slept both of Kennedy's books
were knock-offs of Winston Churchill
books and there's a certain controversy
did he write his own books well if he
probably did but they were written first
by Winston Churchill the same books
where Winston Churchill did a book at
the on British political leadership at
the turn of the century which was
exactly the same as profiles encourage
some of the sentences were exactly the
same and why England slept which was
Kennedy's college thesis was taken from
and often repeated Winston Churchill's
book while England slept you have the
similar similarity to the language in
the
no it's in the back why isn't that
plagiarism and why isn't that roundly
criticized on his part on anybody's I
mean other work out isn't this isn't yes
doesn't really apply we consider
plagiarism but I'm a professional writer
and I don't think that it was or the the
general public considers that sort of
thing to be plagiarism how come well I
think it's like any other business it's
only of interest to the people who do it
and the men journalism in a way is
probably plagiarism from from the
beginning in that you're using other
people's words and kind now if something
gets in LexisNexis I think it probably
goes on forever long after you and I are
are here but I I think it's only a thing
that is of concern to two people in the
business why England slept in profiles
of courage play what role in his
political visibility a great role they
were both bestsellers profiles
encouraged 1 a 1 a Pulitzer Prize which
was an intellectual ornament that
Kennedy very badly wanted that he felt
he felt that ease well I don't know that
he was an intellectual but he was
certainly at ease with ideas and he
enjoyed doing that he intended to write
his memoirs and I think he thought he
would do it pretty well it it was a
thing he thought was worth worthwhile in
his life which he considered a pursuit
of excellence although other people me
among them might characterize it as a
race against boredom and he was he was a
politician he couldn't stand to be alone
he couldn't stand silence and he
structured his life with as much
stimulation as possible he do you have
any idea whether the Pulitzer board or
governing board back then knew that he
had taken this language from the Winston
Churchill books I don't know if they did
Arthur Kroc was a was the major force in
the Pulitzer Prizes in those days he
certainly knew but he was the one who
got Kennedy to the prize anybody but
John Kennedy was not the first of the
last to get a Pulitzer Prize through
hole
Arius kinds he was thinking about crock
I wanted to and and about Kennedy and
they they ended very badly they came to
dislike each other intensely and one of
the reasons was that croc was a great
champion of moistu an BAE who was the
minister of prey the breakaway Katanga
province when there's a civil war in the
Belgian Congo and the idea of croc and
other people was the Chum base should be
brought to America and he was a
right-winger in that context and there
would be rallies and things like that
from Canada refused to let him have a
visa and at one point Kennedy in a
speech to a smaller group said that I'll
be glad to bring more zombie over to
speak to Congress if Arthur croc will
invite him for lunch at the Metropolitan
Club zombie I should humbly was
blackened with those clothes were all
segregated then and croc was a great
champion in that me ask you some
questions about you where where were you
born New York City City I was born
across the street from Gracie Mansion
and then grew up in Jersey City what was
your family like my father was a
Republican politician who through great
Locke gives the starving lawyer really
we live in a three-room apartment
everyone a fifth floor walk-up I was
appointed to judge because the new
constitution in New Jersey required an
equal number of judges in each county
from each party and he was the only
Republican in Hudson County New Jersey
as far as I could tell and my my mother
he had been a musician of my mother than
an actress that's when they met and he
was quite he was quite a guy in terms of
bringing up his father had run off and
he could my father loved responsibility
and he took care of all these families
how many brothers and sisters one
everyone embrace the athletic director
at Columbia where'd you go to school I
went to Stevens Institute of Technology
in Hoboken I'm a mechanical engineer by
education when'd you get into journalism
I worked in a factory
in New Jersey and Phillipsburg New
Jersey out on the Delaware River I was
an engineer there I hated it I wasn't
good at it and I didn't like corporate
life either and I didn't like the
complaints of my fellows and I found a
guy in the town who wanted to start an
inspector he'd been in advertising sales
when we started a newspaper together and
I did that at night with no one knowing
it for about a year until we got it off
the ground the Phillipsburg Free Press
that still exists out there and then
what then well then I knew I was not
born to be a manager and I did the pet
the paper became successful and we had
employees we had to start with three
people at 50 and I was the general
manager and the editor and I just did
not like being the boss I'd see people
would think I was lying to them and when
I said there's no money we were still
paying off the debts we started with and
I couldn't I didn't like it and I went
to the north news as a reporter I got
lucky on a couple stories then I went to
the Herald Tribune hired me in New York
in 1965 and the Trib folded in 66 and
the time the New York Times hired me and
I stayed there through the early 70s and
then went out on my own to write books
and I also went in on the founding of
New York magazine which was old Herald
for viewing people Tom Wolfe and Jimmy
Breslin clay Felker Yoshiki Gloria
Steinem all of us had had a connection
with the Trib one her kids did Deb and
now if you want to say did you vote for
John Kennedy in 1960 no I voted for here
the first person who's ever asked me
that question I mean since that day I
voted for Nixon I was I was in a
Republican Hogzilla I was not I was in
college at the time but the Republicans
made up the construct of my life at that
time
have you changed your politics since
then my politics are quite different now
I'm not registered while I am risen
apart emma is the Democrat to vote for
my wife who was running in California
for what she ran this year for the last
year for the state Senate did she went
she lost the Tom Hayden as a matter of
fact it was a 3-way race it was very
close it was a very interesting piece of
business to see it from that side but
she has her name is Katherine O'Neill
she doesn't use Reeves and she's pretty
well known politically
in the West Coast she had water I love
telling story she was a 29 year old
housewife when the local Democratic Club
shows up all its candidates there were
all white male lawyers and she ran on
her own and got and won the primary and
then came within a couple hundred votes
does 1972 of being the first woman in
the California State Senate we then went
and lived various parts of the world and
when we decided to go back to California
she decided she'd run again pretty much
in the same district but Tom Hayden I
was a very rich man and spent a billion
a quarter dollars on on the state Senate
campaign when did you move permanently
to California uh 1999 well now yes in
nineteen nineteen ninety what do you do
I think I noticed you teach also I teach
political science had a professorship at
UCLA any idea why you got into this
business really got into the business of
writing the first place and who was
there anybody out there that encouraging
uh my mother so she encouraged me I
always want to be a writer I just
happened to grow up in circumstances
that's all I wanted to do I that it's
the thing that I I but I grew up in
Jersey City I had good marks in high
school there were no such things as
guidance in that in that world and
whatnot if you went to college it was
either to be a lawyer a doctor an
engineer and my father was a lawyer and
I didn't love what I saw him doing
I knew I could never be a doctor so I
thought I'd be an engineer when I was
only in later life that I learned who
could just sit and read books and that
was an education how many books have you
written this is the eighth which one of
those did you enjoy the most the one
writing the book I wrote on Alexis de
Tocqueville this was a hard piece it was
hard I think this looks easy I hope it
reads easy but it's hard to make things
easy I did a book retracing alexis de
tocqueville travels across the United
States
what year 1983 and why did you like that
the best well I was walking in great
steps and I was living I did it from his
notes I went the same places that he had
gone and talked to the modern
equivalents of the people he had talked
to
working from his original note so that I
was able I thought I hoped to see
America whole in the sense that I was
seeing it in two centuries in two
periods a hundred and fifty years apart
I'd read his notes I'd go question he
question John Quincy Adams I question
Richard Nixon asked them the same
questions and again and again got about
the same answers what caused you to
change your politics from Richard Nixon
to being a Democrat where are you
liberal Duncan I'm a liberal Democrat uh
I I don't know it came naturally I don't
remember as my father would have said
backsliding into to this but I don't I
don't remember any it could have been as
simple as the fact is when I went to
Phillipsburg it was that was essentia it
was a working-class town it was a
democratic town and when I immersed
myself in the politics of that place it
may well have been that that was the
reason I just but it was I just I had
then I think I probably had more
sympathy because I'm a little older but
I didn't have a lot of sympathy with the
Republicans and in those days in the
ideology not the people now that you
spent all this time with John Kennedy
six and a half years and when was the
last word written by the way sometime in
early July of this year you know would
you vote for him for president today uh
today yeah I would vote for him for
president day but he could he would not
be President today he his health
problems would have become public and
they were just too severe and too
debilitating to make it to make it
possible today's press and and political
context are such the man was taking in
constant pain was taking every drug
known to man including being injected
within fetta means dr. max Jackson later
to be known as dr. feelgood traveled
secretly with Kennedy to to keep him up
and and he was the stereo the
corticosteroids these things all had
side effects including depression
increased sexual desire was one
one side effect all that would have come
out including the fact that he was lying
about having Addison's disease which was
a terminal disease that he kept in check
by stashing medication and safety
deposit boxes around the world because
he was the first out of Sounion to ever
survive dramatic surgery which trauma
triggers the the disease is a is a
withering away of the adrenaline glands
and when they're gone you die but the
cortisone could could substitute they
found in during the war but his
operation without his name on it was so
famous among doctors that his entire
medical history was in the Journal of
the American Medical Association in 1957
without his name it just said the 37
year old man but in today the press
would have found it
he's tell us right and early in the book
that he lied he like very easily that
body lying in America bothers me I mean
to an enormous extent I think that it's
undermining both the democracy and the
Republic people can't people are not
being punished for lying in that time
you were punished more for lying but he
was he was fast alighted one of the
reasons Khrushchev beat up on him so
badly was that Kennedy had told people
that he had studied at the London School
of Economics under Harold Laski but he
had never been there I said but the
whole lot everyone thought that he this
was a real scholar on Marxism John
Kennedy and on communism but he knew
almost nothing about it was the reason
that Khrushchev was able to tie him in
knots at the Vienna summit in June of
1961 and Kennedy sitting there defending
colonialism and imperialism and military
dictatorships and whatnot because he
just he went in there and tried to
defend the status quo against a trained
dialectician and he was eaten alive and
he walked out of that room and and said
we have to go into Vietnam we have to
confront them because they think I'm too
weak and and for
Paige no I lost my place page three
hundreds when I was looking at you quote
there's it's a the set up is this is all
around the steel pricing and and you say
your Kennedy laughed but within hours he
was angry again after watching the
15-minute NBC Nightly News he thought
anchorman Chet Huntley was being too
kind to big steel this is that where he
jawbone the steel prices thought he
picked up the phone and gotten Newton
Minow chairman of the Federal
Communications Commission quote did you
see that goddamn thing on
huntley-brinkley I thought they were
supposed to be our friends I want you to
do something about that you do something
about this unquote Meno 1962 or whatever
what's that about that's how he operated
he did that every day but did he you
know he called the Federal
Communications Commission Chairman which
was run illegal none of well III
certainly not ethical others but if it
wasn't legal he did many many things
that were illegal I mean they there was
there was much wider spread wiretapping
that kind of thing the Justice
Department searched George lodges and
Eddie McCormack service records when
Teddy ran against him for the Senate in
1962 and as far as I can tell the
obviously the public didn't know about
many of these things but as far as I can
tell they thought that that was the way
the game was played what about that did
was NBC News at that time friendly to
the president I mean were they friends
is that the way was that the right way
for him to characterize it well the
friendly didn't mean that they were
having tea together it meant that they
had never done anything that caused
Kennedy pain and he I there were many
instances the book where he picks up
phones and calls reporters and if if
saying their friends was murdered I mean
he would he would bully reporters and
threaten them and scream at them Hugh
SIA T of Time magazine got that
treatment while Kennedy was
was welcoming John Glenn back from the
first orbit he was reading out here to
hit a real temper I've got it here I'll
read it and say no but I want to ask you
what this source is on something like
you haven't remember what the Newton
Minow thing source was it wasn't Newton
Minow who I talked to I don't remember
what the what the source of that phone
call is maybe Salinger but I don't know
the the other one is from sides-- files
to to Time magazine it was never
published in time but it was in the
files he's the first time this had been
published this site yes I think so I
shouldn't have said that so quickly some
of Saudi stuff is some ism they're
talking about the cover of gentleman's
quarterly right do you want to explain
that and I want to ask you a question
yeah well Kennedy was incredibly upset
and he spent Kent John Kennedy spent
hours on this every day he was
extraordinarily interested in what was
said about him he and he had also been a
newspaper reporter he had worked for
Hearst what this was about was
gentlemen's quarterly GQ was fat men's
fashion magazine and they had a picture
of Kennedy on it Kennedy didn't like
that because the the Kennedys were
pretty homophobic and they considered GQ
a magazine for homosexuals which they
use much more colorful language than I
but let me know you quote Robert Kennedy
saying he called it a [ __ ] rag yeah the
and so that didn't bother him as much as
the fact that Time magazine then said he
had posed for exclusive photographs for
GQ which was not true they had used file
photographs of some sort and what
Kennedy was mad at was the fact that
people thought he was posing for his
Bobby said this [ __ ] rag and he then and
he worked hew over pretty well over that
stopping to say how wonderful it was for
John Glenn that John Glenn was back
safely back to her safely and to hang up
the phone and then went right back at
outsid again but these were that was the
way he operated it was and what he did I
mean we feared the whole thing about
news management everything whatever
anyone thinks of it before John Kennedy
people in this town in Washington
covered the agencies and covered the
bureaucracies out there and whatnot
Kennedy almost immediately centralized
all press release work into the center
into himself so that that's when we
built up this gigantic staffing of the
White House because he made the the
White House the center of action to the
point that there was no point in being
out at the agricultural department
because everything was going to come
through the White House the way the
White House wanted it so suddenly you
had this centralization of a media
control this scene you've done it again
Kennedy snapped its ID back inside his
office done what side he said and later
on Kennedy has quoted President
Kennedy's quote I'm not kidding talking
about the GQ magazine and the
characterization characterizations that
hew starting made in his column I'm
goddamn sick and tired of it this is all
a lie I never posed for any magazine
never posed for any picture will correct
its side he said but that didn't stop
Kennedy
I never posed for any picture anybody
who reads this would think I was crazy
he goes on and there's some on the next
page it is strong language did that did
the press get treated that way and did
they go along with being treated that
way by a president yes and yes who I
mean there was was what characterize how
the press felt about John Kennedy back
in those years well I think that the
they had about the same feelings that we
didn't I think that they probably there
was a wonderful generational match that
that worked for them after all their
generation was now taking over power you
get some of that of that with Clinton
too but the way the press in the country
was structured then these and and most
of the the big time magazine was still
run by its founder it was a very
personal operation if a reporter messed
with
president united states particularly
this president united states i henry
luce was going to get a phone call about
postal rates so that the we didn't have
the access and the spontaneity and all
of that that we now have the information
is out and about before anyone can try
to block at these days the other thing
is a lot of your the reviews say that
you don't talk about the womanizing
brian i found a lot of references in
here are you surprised when you read
that that you in your reviews that this
book doesn't deal with womanizing III
actually have been mildly surprised by
that but of course it doesn't deal with
womanizing because that most of the
other books are on womanizing that's
about all they're about my major take on
it was one people who live that kind of
life have to lie all the time so the
part of the facility is a liar comes
from comes from covering up clandestine
affairs of of some sort and that it was
incredibly corrupting i thought i think
that to him it was like tennis in a way
and and it took less time than
scheduling tennis games but the
logistics were a heck of a lot more
complicated so that everyone up to dean
rusk had to run these operations with
helicopters and cars and whatever to get
women here and there and then they'd be
with kennedy for twelve minutes or
something and they were gone and he was
with and then many of these people were
proud to do that because they felt that
it it was a rite of initiation that they
had been brought in they were closer
that corruption of his own people and
breaking them essentially many of them
was what i found interesting and
significant about the womanizing the
fact of it itself i didn't it had to do
with lying and with the corruption of
other people where it was important we
were talking about Daisy Buchanan in a
way and in the great gatsby the this
rich boy does whatever he wants and
there are people there to clean up the
mess whether it involves paying off
or whatever it takes and that John
Kennedy at least to me is pretty
unattractive
here's that page you've got pictures of
several of the women that were
supposedly in his life this is Ben
Bradley's former Oh mr. claw Mary Meyer
and Judith Exner next to her Ryan that
is not what you defection would look
like though of course when this was all
happening and then down below that you
have merrill monroe and Jayne Mansfield
no Angie Dickinson Angie Dickinson how
do you know me well how do you you've
got a footnote back here you've got a
book that you refer to in the Braun
about fiddle and faddle two of what
secretaries that work for run that's
what they referred to James gigolo that
was a look okay I use that for a
particular reason but yes but how can
you be sure of all these stories that
they were accurate and then you listen a
lot of other names tempest storm blaze
star he had relations with those people
that was the courting I didn't use that
in the book I mean that's according to
gig law the I start started with
airplane logs and and coming and going
logs beginning with the inauguration
when Angie Dickinson was with him during
the the inaugural after after mrs.
Kennedy went home and a lot of up to the
point and in some cases some people told
me particularly grand women in this in
this city but the none of the people I
don't know about blaze storm and one
that giggly I was list although he's a
very respected teacher and whatnot but
the people I use in the book either
I was totally satisfied that they were
telling the truth or people who handle
the logistics of moving them in and out
were telling the truth and there were
there were a number but I part of me
wanted to the whole idea of the book was
to what it's like to be president what a
president does how it how it feels only
42 people know and I did not want to get
myself drowned by
by what was in some ways the least
interesting part of his life in a
relatively small part although it would
be foolish to ignore it or to pretend it
didn't happen
another thing that you say is that his
reputation for reading 1500 words speed
reading a minute speed reading you know
it was not actually it was total
fabrication
who fabricated it well it worked like
uni Shriver sat next to Henry Luce at a
at a dinner party and talked to him
about how fast or how much and how fast
her brother read and when the next day
Luce called up the hue side he was then
there White House correspondent of Time
and said you know check this out that
Kennedy can read this fast so Kennedy
was open to it again it was part of
presenting an image of of
intellectualism and he gave side he gave
the president of reading test and he
have 700 words a minute which is what
most intelligent college-educated people
read it somewhere around that rate and
Kenny then then they went into a
negotiation with Kennedy saying we can't
say if that's low and what not and they
finally compromise on as I recall 1200
words a minute which is what was printed
and then again it was like the London
School of Economics Kennedy said he had
taken a speed-reading course and in fact
he had signed up for it but never went
you right in the back Kennedy's death
was followed by a wave of reverence that
created and cemented the Camelot myth
JFK was enshrined as war hero family man
and world leader he became a symbol of
toughness and peace helpful idealism and
realistic political sense brilliant
intelligence and compassion Grace and
salty good humor all at once how much of
that was he well he was all of those
things he was a lot of others and and
things existed in combination but it all
of that happened Jacqueline Kennedy at a
large extent orchestrated that Camelot
was never mentioned while Kennedy was
the law
the word was never mentioned it was mrs.
Kennedy brought that to Teddy white in
doing a picture of in doing a portrait
of him a posthumous portrait of them in
Life magazine but he was a hell of a guy
I mean this if every person I talked to
said that they thought he was the most
charming human being they ever met that
he lit up a room and that there was
incredible pleasure just being in in his
company Paul Feig's book was called the
pleasure of his company and so he was
all of those things and that got him to
the White House he charmed his way
incident politics is institutionalized
John and he got that far but he was
those things did she know about all the
other things that you've talked about
here and others have talked about the
you know the speed-reading the
plagiarism that I don't know in the hell
I think drugs and women and things like
that she knew about I've the other
things worth knowing and that did that
Bobby Kennedy was Jack's political wife
a man or a woman needs someone they can
turn to they trust completely and no
they have no other axe to grind but
their own interest and usually that
that's a man a husband or wife
Jacqueline Kennedy had no interest
whatever in any of those things and
Bobbie served that function for his
brother but she knew about his other
activities it was a very tense play
sometimes why did she didn't want to
paint the picture that this paints with
Teddy white after he was killed
well she is you know she was first she
was 30 years old when all this happened
and she was our princess died it was a
very similar story in many ways and but
she's also a very very bright woman and
she's got the choice of facing history
as as the princess of this wonderful
golden period or as a young wife who was
being deceived by a lusty and sometimes
pretty nasty husband and I think she
made an intelligent choice why should
she want low in that stuff go back to
the
the library you say the family has the a
lot of stuff all tied up how do they do
that
the under our system the families
control the presidential libraries which
is an outrage they should be controlled
outside the family and they should just
be there there for history the way that
it's been done ICANN is that they you
it's like Kennedy's theories about how
you control the press that is you've got
to get it in you've got to stop it
before the first mention because once as
a first mention everyone else can lean
on that in the libraries there are
there's enormous amounts of material
that have not been indexed and
categorized that's done by professional
librarians who work for the federal
government not only the Kennedy Library
at all federal libraries there are none
of those people anymore those are the
kind of people who were eliminated in
job freezes it's easy to to what let
librarians go so that the whole process
has largely been stopped and only with
family permission doc can you look at
can one look at certain things and only
with the permission of this kind of
Kennedy industry does Arthur
Schlessinger for instance has been
allowed to see things that no one else
has ever been allowed to see because the
family trusts them and that was a long
time ago but they it helped him
enormously a lot of that stuff is not
public from other places but there yeah
there is a an obvious invisible attempt
to control what information comes out
the the most striking example to me was
my discovery that max Jacobson treated
Kennedy which was stunning stunning the
president was being shot up this way and
max Jacobson became known as dr.
feelgood in the 1970s when the New York
Times first New York magazine The New
York Times found out that he was having
his medical license taken away because
he couldn't account for what amounted to
Galan upon gallon of amphetamines where
you know where did all this go from the
day his name appeared in the New York
Times
any flight manifest housing lists when
the president travels
that was indexed or cataloged after that
date when the New York Times story ran
is classified anything before it showed
the trip to Vienna I max Jacobson is
shown as being housed with the military
attache z' and his coming and goings are
recorded and all this paperwork there's
no one then the people handling those
papers had no idea what the name max
Jacobson meant nor did anyone else into
the middle 70s and anything cataloged
after that point
he's been kind of excised from history
and to what extent I don't know but that
stuff does go on all the time yeah we're
running out of time there's a couple
issues I want to quickly ask you about
the missile gap did you find anything
new he promised or he he told the
country in 1916 when he ran that there
was a missile gap was there well it was
a tremendous missile gap but it was all
in our favor it's possible at the time
he was saying that we had 1500
deliverable nuclear weapons than they
had four or five although the entire the
entire United States was galvanized by
the language of a missile gap that they
had more than we had it I should say in
fairness that the missile gap figures
even the Kennedy used in accurately and
that Henry Kissinger was the great
champion of at that time were
projections but that we totally our
intelligence was totally wacko the
reason there was a missile crisis was
that the Russians were so far behind
that Khrushchev began we had them
surrounded by land based and Polaris
missiles he gambled Khrushchev gamble
and said sent almost half of his stuff
to Cuba we had no southern facing
defenses we had defended the country
electronically from the north and he
thought if he could get in behind us
that there would be a balance of terror
in the world because the true balance of
terror was aimed then only at the
Soviets not at us did he call for the
assassination or did he engineer the
assassination of Zia Minh you know he
didn't call for it but he engineered it
he signed off on it in essence although
that word is never used on paper except
for the two or three times that I was
able to find but I would answer that
question yes it was he asked that
question publicly and what did he answer
if he was he was never asked that
question
publicly to my knowledge he always
denied any any u.s. involved in an
assassination but occurred we were
spending enormous amounts of money and
on the day he died we were passing
weapons to try to assassinate Cuba I've
tried to assassinate Castro I'm sorry
that's what I want to ask you was what
involvement in diem and the
assassination attempts or did did he try
to assassinate Fidel Castro yes although
everybody has done there's a memo in
there for Martha Schlesinger on how the
outline should be done to protect the
president the whole idea is to have a
cut out and not to Bobbie oversaw all of
that McNamara was a little bit of it but
you these people did not operate without
the president was on the president's
orders how many letters were exchanged
between Nikita Khrushchev and these
private letters John Kennedy my memory
is that I don't remember penalty was
about thirty all but one of now been
released because I got some of them
released and then I also for me the
great kind of research coup was a the
messenger between them was a a KGB
Colonel a major named your give [ __ ]
off who ostensibly was in the United
States as the editor of Soviet Life
magazine and english-language magazine
but he in general sometimes Pierre
Salinger worthy carried the messages
between Kennedy and Khrushchev and I was
able to find him in Moscow after the
Soviet Union began falling apart are you
surprised at some of the things you've
got in this book that have not been
discovered by the press so far I guess I
am but I mean it's an 800-page book it's
it's 400,000 words give us some examples
of what you what you're surprised they
haven't found yet I think that the the
section on one the president's health I
suppose has not been heavily emphasized
and also the whole business we should
check this on presidents the fact that
he was not against the Berlin Wall he
was forward it seems to me a revelation
of since we've lived with this myth
years but nobody has particularly it's
amazing how how much of that has been
forgotten I thought that that would be a
major in the mail and would be discussed
at great length and probably the single
thing that is most unbelievable but I
was able to dig out because of Averell
Harriman's papers because he had
recorded the conversations and that is
that kennedy tried to get Khrushchev to
consider a joint American Soviet
airstrike at China to destroy their
nuclear capability I would that and they
literally was lined up it was going to
be done like a firing squad that is
neither the Russian crew nor the
American crew he would know that they
had the real weapon one weapon would be
a dud one weapon would be real as they
doing a firing squad so every man can
think he didn't fire the fatal shot if
he wanted to accrue chef turned him down
do you have a neither book I uh I'm
gonna do a little book on the Oregon
Trail but I don't have another book not
on this I have to fill fill the well
before I come back at something like
that what would what would make this a
success for you this book authoritative
success for me because the reviews have
talked about what I wanted to do which
is one I wanted to show who John Kennedy
was he wasn't this sort of clown or a
lothario figure wrong he did all those
things but that's what not not what he
was about and that I wanted a book when
the New York Times review came out and
said it this makes us for the first time
look at what the presidency really is
and what it means that was enough for me
I was ready to go home and get a tan
this is the book it's called President
Kennedy profiled power and our guest is
the author Richard Reeves thank you very
much
thanks so much fun